our life is a the next mayor of Gotham
system this is an important day for
these two heads incumbent mayor Hamilton
Hill and the Challenger Gotham District
Attorney Harvey Dent and it's also
important to you the citizens of Gotham
will soon head to the polls to decide
the picture over home a city that's
based in share of hardships in recent
years
at least we know why they weren't
responding Gordon we found one of your
patrols they've been terminated as you
are in case there's been a Chinese to
tonight's program first over a business
writer I hate to be a downer but these
hostages I don't like their chances
never anybody issues if we're quick and
decisive no one else has to die if you
say so but penguins playing for keeps
fanatics always do you'll do get out
here keep it quiet back there these guys
are armed to the teeth and we need a new
motor right on you do that yes yes thank
you for volunteering please no go on
then introduce the candidates stage
right huh all right I'll get you started
but this is your show three hostiles
gotta take them out quietly
come be my and on the right always
smiling to your face whatever your name
is
questions I send questions
normal
fortunate
sure you go Russ I sure you gon scratch
avoid the kicker
smart
keep your redstone make for the police
line and now a word from our sponsors
and sisters in hell you have nothing to
fear we are the children of markup we
are here to end the masquerade and
expose the corruption as long in your
city for too long not like your esteemed
mayor of positive opinion innocence I
knew this was too big for Oswald alone
someone else is pulling the strings smut
lets someone else did it don't work go i
love you know what to do
ah
Oh
by the city pretend you know everybody
ain't got them so that moderator gets
shot on live TV what's going on in there
first off we should see the cool season
for you we're at a time Batman the brass
is going to dance with us to trust on
stage
corrupt politicians and about the
corrupt elite the men's fortunes are
built on courses may like your brain
Aziz
when you don't want to say roll that
tape
subject line Todd I thought your father
was dead subject on Esther Cobblepot
you've been declared criminally insane
and committed to argument definitely as
a ward of the state please don't you had
your chance you should have made the
deal we offered you give her the drop
Thomas together you were warned Esther
you know I always get what I want
commence the procedure give her a tour
she woke up
certainly not imagine entrance
go
please
I took out Thomas Wayne that that was
all him he didn't know when to stop I
hadn't killed because of it back what a
little um so Lisa for anyone else
where's your may Bruce Wayne your
biggest supporter and isn't enough bash
man the revolutions already started it's
here later joy what dead go and whatever
though I'll crush every bone in your
body I knew you say something like that
take a fire damn it
Harvey where's the maniac gonna mess we
need paramedics over here now
you